Film Courage: What does the saying "people
watch people first" mean?
Phil Hawkins, Filmmaker: Oh!
I feel like I'm being quoted back at
myself because I say that all the time.
Someone really clever said that. I don't know
who, what, how this is because and this is from
love my mistakes right because I became obsessed
in making my own short films, about how everything
looked and it had to look good. Everything
had to look...I had to have that camera,
I had to have that lens, I had to have that
lighting and you sort of forget that people
watch people first. There's no point in going
to all the effort and time and money and emotion
(everything) making a film if your actors are
miscast. It's just pointless. You could have
the best script in the world, you could have
Chinatown but with really horrible actors it'd
be a horrible movie you know? Whereas Chinatown
with amazing actors shot on a phone might be not
your cup of tea but it'd still be a good movie. I
feel like there's a few things. Directors can be
quite scared of actors because I feel you have to
really put yourself out there emotionally for them
to meet you where you need to be met and that can
be a scary thing for some people or some people
like to hide behind the technical side of things,
like hide behind the monitor and maybe just enjoy
the technical side of it first but I always say
if you don't love actors and I love actors right,
a lot of my friends are actors. I could never
do the job. It's even harder than what I do,
all that rejection and lack of control
makes me sick thinking about it
but I love them. I love working with actors,
it's a real joy. If you're not that person
then go be a DP or go direct you know Coke cans
and commercials kind of thing and the same way
if you're into actors you're not into camera go
direct theater i mean you've you've you know i
i don't like this idea that oh you get actors
directors and you get technical directors like
your job is to do both when you make
a film because it is a visual medium
as well as being a dramatic media in terms
of performance so you have to and you may
have strengths and weaknesses in the both but
you can't just reject one especially when it
comes to performances um and if you don't agree
with me go next time you're on set or even just
you know go be an extra in something or go and
you know take part go stand the other side of
that camera and know how it feels to be that
alone and wonder why you're not getting those
performances or you're not getting that thing
that's coming across and being frustrated because
you know you you can hide behind the
technical side whereas the actors really can't
and they need a helping hand so you really
need to love the form and understand the form
in order to get the best out of the actors
because people watch people first you know it
you know i've sort of mediocre film with amazing
performances will be a much better film than the
other way around um and that that's what
we go to films for right is to experience
worlds and stories through other people whether
that's a green alien or someone that looks like
you you know they're all characters it's all we're
looking we're searching for emotional connection
um and um and that comes obviously from
the performance first and everything else
helps that performance i feel that when i uh
i'm directing anything whether it's a commercial
something one line or an emotional scene a film i
feel like oh what i'm doing is setting the stage
and creating the environment for the actor to do
the best job you know to be in that moment and
be in a safe space and feel supported and that's
and that's what's most important over knowing your
lenses knowing what your shot list is you know all
that is obviously important but and maybe it comes
with experience maybe it comes with knowing
being on enough sets or knowing the room but
i'm very protective of my actors like um because
i feel that they uh their phones need to be
respected like my god if you are on your phone on
set when someone's acting uh i will not be a happy
bunny you know it's just disrespectful um and uh
i know i'm um uh i know i'm not alone in that and
also i know that people some people don't care but
i just i just feel that that's what you need to do
especially especially on your first films
because and this is what i say about
if you're going to pay for your camera pay for
your actors because you know if you can pay for
your actors maybe you can get into that agency
or get that casting directive that can get that
better actor that is maybe a bit more experienced
than you but don't be intimidated because they're
going to make you look way better than you
are you know um in what they do on screen and
and that's that's an asset and you shouldn't be
afraid of that you should embrace it as a director
i know you've talked about preparation being very
important for you what do you do when an actor
shows up on set and they're not prepared um what
do i do i think i mean there's a few things with
that maybe if they're not just if they're not
prepared because they've just not learned lines
for example they're obviously and you need to
shoot that scene there and then you know you just
get into very practical things of cue cards and
boards and or maybe try and shoot the other side
first so the actor gets into the flow you
know it becomes very practical and it's um
not being prepared emotionally that's that's
trickier that feels like that's part of my job to
have foreseen it you know like the like there's
an art to kind of scheduling something where
on day one you're not going to do the most
emotional performance because everyone's flying
their feet even the actors are finding their feet
in the role like you're going to save that until
maybe the middle of the schedule when everyone's
not really tired you know um so there's a real art
that comes to that um so hopefully you've thought
about that or you can have you know i like to
um talk to actors uh either obviously
every act is different but on a feature
we'll maybe talk about what's i'm expecting
the next day to be um and uh and if that's
something that's emotional i'll maybe just plant
a few seeds at the end of the day um so they can
kind of be prepared when they get there or i'll
be there when they as soon as they get to make
up as soon as they get to their trailer as soon
as they get there to go okay today's a big day
what do you need you know how are you
feeling what because you don't know
someone could have and there's all the unexpected
stuff like someone could have broken up with their
girlfriend that night you know and they turn
up the set and they're supposed to be this
big jovial happy scene and they're just not in
the mood like you know um so you know a million
things can happen but it's your it's your
job to try and um set the stage for them to
do the performance they need to do that day and
whether that as i say it's a practical way of
just getting through the day because they've had a
few to drink last night and not learn their minds
or or something more emotional it's kind of your
job to to be prepared for that as a director have
you ever skimped on preparing for a film and if
so what happened uh yeah i have actually um and um
it was mainly it was so i did an indie feature
that was very kind of low budget um and um i was
quite busy during prep and and it was one of those
where we didn't quite know the money was gonna
happen and then it suddenly sort of happened and i
didn't really have a lot of time to prep so maybe
i'm making excuses for not doing the hard work but
i mean like i shot listed it and i knew about it
but i feel like maybe from a script level um i
didn't live with it more maybe you know i feel
like on reflection i've probably maybe missed a
few beats that uh and i'm not talking huge things
like you know we we i shot the film and we made
it and it works and we saw you know it's all that
but i think i think of him being very critical of
myself was that like maybe not being completely
intimate with the material as much as i wanted
to and i think um uh and i think maybe that was
a bit of a struggle on on the odd scene that
maybe for some of the things we talked about about
not preparing the stage more or maybe thinking
i needed less time to shoot something that i
actually did you know or underestimating how long
action scenes take to shoot sometimes and things
like that so um thing is i i do enjoy and thrive
on being um i want to say under prepared but but
not being completely set in stone what's going to
happen you know uh sometimes i feel like my best
work is isn't is is in the um the spontaneity um
or or um the you know like on you know exam a case
in point on star's origins which i pre-vised and
shot listed and worked on for three years before
i got the shooter i know knew every single
frame of that what that film was going to be
and then you get to set and then you shoot in the
desert and then your actors get sick and then you
suddenly don't have the actors that day that you
need the actors for and then you have to come up
with creative ways of shooting the scene based on
what you have available and piecing it together in
a very different way that now you i see you see it
and you go actually that's probably better but but
um but that spontaneity has forced you to be to
think on your feet creatively and come up with
uh a way of meeting the day a way of meeting
the schedule you know and making things work
so um so yeah i think i mean less lesson
learned from maybe from that film uh
but um you know i'll probably hold my hands up
to a few things some of it was out of my control
in terms of scheduling not prep time and stuff
but i probably should have maybe focused more on
um you know some a particular character arc that
maybe i don't feel like i quite nailed um versus
uh you know some of the other stuff you
know that that i had a limited time.
Questions For The Viewers: How
is this video helpful to you?